[Music]
thank you
why
[Music]
don't you
know
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
bye
whatever
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
welcome to r r with the Lords and this
is Lord King and my man Lord addict uh
here where we talk about the latest and
greatest in all entertainment especially
the movies uh right now we're going to
talk about a couple of movies uh that we
both got a chance to see attic sorcer
movies I saw a movie uh most awesome
movies he saw a movie and usually we
talk about Netflix and stuff but it's
been very hectic with a lot of games
coming out in my man doing a ton of
reviews uh he's uh knee-deep in the
thick of it
yeah so have you guys checked out the
show from yet season two just dropped
has lost Vibes and way more Savage a
touch of redfall in there too due to the
town that is takes place in cheers to in
salute the Lords now he did put that in
for the attic show but it was it was
entertainment related so I think he
might have just got them confused
okay have you ever seen from no I
haven't me and Grace literally just
watched the first season like three or
four days ago
the whole you binge watch the whole
first season it's that good like I I
would say
because it's like lost is about the
characters but I would say lost is more
about the island than it is about the
characters this is the same thing like
they keep
they keep giving you a little bit
of information on the characters but at
the same time they're they're making
the place they are more deeper and more
mystery you know what I'm saying yeah
all right well something uh on my bucket
list because I'm still watching Petty so
I I finished that whole thing I bet you
did and I want to finish it uh like I
got to a very good part but like yo I'm
telling you so many things have been
going on so uh we didn't do r r with the
Lord's
um
what was it uh last two weeks ago last
week so um we have movies for two weeks
right and I I can tell you about uh two
of the movies that I saw two weeks ago
and this is what I was going to bring to
the table you know two weeks ago well
one was the Pope's Exorcist with uh
Russell Crowe
in the beginning of the movie you know
um well let me start off by saying the
whole idea of this movie it's really uh
old versus new
it's like young Bloods versus old school
and you have that dichotomy in the
church right now on those who truly
believe in the old teachings and who uh
don't believe in old teachings and
believes like the devil is
um a myth and those things aren't really
true it's just something to keep people
in line and then you have the old guard
that actually have a chance to witness
this stuff so being the Pope's Exorcist
which is Russell Crowe uh he gets a
chance to see some of the darkest
dirtiest worst things in the world
and uh we get to a family that had
inherited this house father died and you
know the family inherited this house
from his family
and it's like in some like weird
Countryside on the hill and some creepy
creepy thing that they just wanted to
fix it up and sell it and they get there
to go do so and the the little boy gets
possessed by some entity and the whole
back story is the church did some evil
stuff back in the days and they locked
off this demonic presence that's under
this house that these guys got and the
you know the entity launched itself on
to the child and you know it's funny
what you're describing the Evil Dead
rise like
but but this it it it's it's you know
the pope is here so you know Pope's
Exorcist is there so this is where a
little Divergence happens
the demon acts asses for
him Russell Crowe
specifically
I want him I want that Pope oh I mean
that that Exorcist I want is like bring
me the priest
and that's the priest that he wanted
I feel like there's a reason for that
he's trying to take control over just
him or something I don't know well yeah
the demon wanted to take control of him
and go back to the Vatican and control
the Vatican
and there's some Bleak points in this
film where possibly this stuff can
happen well it was a turning point in
the film where I wasn't truly impressed
with the film as much because when I
come from Exorcist So when I get a
chance to see some stuff like this I
want to see heads turning I want to see
vomit I want to see all types of you
know demonic possession type of things
and it wasn't just giving me that until
a point in the movie where it flipped on
top of his head and it seems like Calvin
had the script in the beginning but they
gave it to the real dudes at the end and
from I think it's like the last 45
minutes to an hour of the movie
it takes off it gets wings and it takes
flight and Russell Crowe gives an
Immaculate job I didn't know that he
speaks so much Italian in the way that
he does very fluent in Italian the movie
is you know it's bilingual so you get a
chance you know to read some stuff at
the bottom as you're watching it's a
nice view it's something to you know if
you're into these type of spiritual
movies it's something to see I give it
three popcorn because like I told you
before the beginning of the film
didn't do it for me but that last hour
or 45 minutes definitely brought a
crescendo in and it's something that
they're going to build a franchise to
because they lead it on to uh making a
sequel to it so maybe something to look
out for you know
yeah so one of the movies that you sent
me to make the thumbnail with which I
actually really liked the thumbnail I
made this week uh just adding that in
there but um
was uh the Covenant I I really enjoyed
what I saw just from just looking at the
trails and I'm a I'm a fan of Jay I'm a
b-roll with you I'm a fan of Jake like I
feel like Jake Jake's a great actor like
fantastic actor and uh I was hitting of
Kingdom like is there a place I can
watch this without going to the movie
theater because I was trying to sneak it
in right before the podcast like for the
show just sneak it in you know just sit
down watch it he's like nah you gotta go
to the movie theater I'm not driving 45
minutes to go watch Jake okay it's not
happening you know this Jake is worth it
this Jake's worth it I gotta drive 45
minutes this weekend to go watch
Guardians so yeah yeah I got to see
Guardians yeah so tell me about the
Covenant and what's funny is there's
another movie called The Covenant oh
yeah well that's an old movie yeah that
was a good movie too I really like that
movie this is the reason why this one is
called guy Richie's the Covenant
and it just well of course guy Richie is
the director and I really like guy
Richie's films his films are really good
like um what was that fontuna that I
just watched a fortune that I just
watched not too long ago I think was a
couple of weeks ago
guy Richie film
well this film is about uh
after 9 11 they send to Iraq at well
Afghanistan 98 000 troops to Afghanistan
98 000 that's that's a huge number
almost 100
.
does that go
well because I need the money
that's really not the truth for the
matter why he picked the job
but he picks the job and um he's The
Interpreter for that group
and they go on this journey where they
build this Bond and they wind up getting
ambushed and I'm I don't want to break
up too much of the movie but I'm gonna
give you the gist of it yeah I want to
apologize to the uh to the chat you as
muted for like 20 seconds my headset
died so that's where you come from is my
headset so I had to rush and get another
another uh charger so I apologize okay
okay he said Mike is mean and Mike is
meeting Mike is me the king you're muted
oh good looking guys all right that was
adequate all right so
uh tell me did y'all get to the part
where I said uh 98 000 troops y'all got
that part right no you just go ahead and
repeat that last like the last game so
there's this there's 98 000 troops that
were sent to Afghanistan and they needed
50 000 interpreters there was
interpreters was told that they would
get visas for them and their families
and they would be able to get safe
Sanctuary to the United States
well we all know that the United States
government uh don't really uphold their
deals this way but uh Jake Gyllenhaal he
had a squad and his Squad was on a
mission and The Interpreter got killed
they needed a new interpreter and they
wind up going uh with this um
this new interpreter a small guy a
little feisty guy but he knows his stuff
now this is based on a true story
and
I'm gonna give you the gist of it I'm
not gonna give you too much of the story
because I I do believe that this is
worth your time your money and your
effort to go see it
Jake and the squad gets ambushed right
they go out and get some Intel some good
Intel they get ambushed Now The
Interpreter that they got right now
used to be a drug Smuggler
he's not the normal interpreter oh so he
he he he he gangster yeah he knows his
way about this he about that life
does he pop off quicker than they do oh
my God yo you'll be amazed at some of
the stuff Ahmad does
and he's like you guys they could live
unless you actually put up like yo it's
crazy but the reason why he hates the
Taliban is because they killed his son
and this guy just all out once Revenge
he wants to take the Taliban down and uh
this government gives him the ability to
do so
and get his family out of there
so
they get ambushed Jake Gyllenhaal gets
kind of semi-captured for a second and
then The Interpreter pops up and The
Interpreter pops up and he goes all out
and
he he makes sure that he takes him out
of there he gets them out of that space
they had to go 100 miles it was a
hundred clicks to get back to base
Jake is shot
he's wounded
this guy
gets them safely back to base
after he gets him back to base
they send Jake home back to his family
and they leave I'm out there
with his family his wife is pregnant
and
Jake is like he can't do this he can't
sleep he can't eat this guy saved his
life because all his memories start
coming flooding back to him on what this
guy actually did to get him to safety
and Jake has to go back and he has to go
back and he has to go get this guy and
it's one of the most
movies about loyalty
if you look at what a covenant means you
know loyal Bond
um Unbreakable
it's it's something that
you hope that you you find in this
lifetime and you know what's funny all I
need all I had to do is see Jake and I
was like it's gonna be a good movie I
can't really name any bad movies he's
been in I just watched a recent movie
with um it's called ambulance it's
awesome it's on Prime TV and I watched
it when I first moved into this new
place and I was just like this dude's
not in any bad movies like he really
isn't and you know the one with his
brother and he told his brother make a
couple of months some money yeah and
then he turns out that he's a good going
into it you know what I like you
obviously this is spoil in that movie
like they ended up liking that dude so
much that the cop live at the end to get
him out of as much trouble as he was
going to be in like he's gonna be in a
ton of trouble but
this this movie
has a truly a good beginning middle and
and is in guy Richie's Fashion on how he
directs and you know big names letting
you know exactly where they are uh what
what place they are or where they're at
it's a really good film I mean this guy
I think it was his name was Tilly
uh officer Tilly and I I believe you
know his wife had his back they put
their house up
they mortgage their house so he can get
the money to go back into Afghanistan to
hire some um Black Ops
to go get this guy go find him and get
him
I'm I'm not gonna lie if if you see one
war movie this year or movie that has
anything to do with uh you know fighting
overseas or you know military I would
highly suggest this film I give this
film The coveted five popcorn five yes
it's it's worth your time your effort
and your money and he doesn't disappoint
is a point where he talks to his his
Sergeant his well his captain because
he's a sergeant he talks to his captain
and he tells them
what he wants what he demands from him
and he's like and you're going to do
this
because I saved your life and you owe me
a debt and you're going to pay this debt
because you're a man that pays what he
owes
and he says it with such fire in his
eyes
and and it's such so much command of
that moment that scene I think that
scene totally encapsulates the film and
that film definitely deserves five high
point definitely that's every last drop
just being a five to you makes me want
to go watch it you know what this Friday
I might it just might be an all-day uh
nowaday movie day I might go watch that
and uh Guardians again
you're gonna really like it if you're a
fan of him you're gonna like it then
it's gonna be something that you care
about all right and the last film that I
saw was air
the story of the Jordans
how they came to be
and all the stuff that it took to get
there
I think Matt Damon and Ben Affleck on
screen is Magic the chemistry did you
know that they were friends like before
you get me famous I didn't know they
lived together and everything yeah it
was yeah like that it got to the point
where like they they couldn't make rent
and like apparently Damon sold a script
that they've been working on for a while
like it was kind of crazy
yeah they they're really good friends
and you can tell by this film that
they're really good friends because the
chemistry pops on screen Chris Tucker is
really good in the role that he plays
this is uh based on real life events uh
Chris Tucker needs to do a rush hour
four and stop playing
I don't know I'm not a real huge fan of
the shallow
yeah
um what's
um Viola Davis
she plays Jordan's mother
I didn't know how intrical Jordan's
mother was to this deal getting done and
for him not to sign what indeed is but
for him to sign with Nike
because Nike wasn't the number one
um basketball sneaker at the time they
were the number one running sneaker but
there wasn't the number one basketball
sneaker they weren't cool Jordan did
that he changed the way the industry
looks at him for uh
how sneaker deals go with athletes and
how how much percentage athletes get and
his mother played a huge role excuse me
in that aspect of that happening so
really good film
if you're a Jordan fan it's uh and you
like them sneakers uh well I don't know
if you like the sneakers would you go
see it but if you're a Jordan fan and
you want to know more about what
happened and how stuff was the movie is
set in the 80s or early 90s uh and it
shows everything on how old Vegas was
would you declare it as a basketball
film or is this like there's no
basketball in it it's just strictly on
the the origin stories of Jordans no
basketball
is this is a this is a how Dale's go
excuse me like how contracts and
negotiations go on how uh you know um
one thing could just did the deal one
thing there's been a few of those maybe
like I think Gucci made one too
um Like An Origin stories uh Facebook
has one
uh there's a lot of like origin stories
but I honestly say that
the only origin store I've ever really
liked was the social network and I don't
know why I think it's because like the
one that was about Facebook yeah the one
the acting
and I guess it's because like low-key
Mark is is not the best person in the
world back then especially back then
it's like the drama
it's just like the pure chaos in that
movie I would never forget when he's
like across the table for him he's like
well our clients said they couldn't have
did he's like he's like me and my people
could buy 10 of these places so stop it
with things like your people don't even
have the Mind intellect to do what I'm
doing
I really enjoyed that movie that was a
good movie
oh this is sort of in that vein
um you know background deals uh Roundup
uh movie you know how the Jordans came
to be and it's based on real life stuff
so I'm not a huge Jordan fan as far as
sneakers go definitely not a huge Jordan
fan as far as basketball goal I'm a
Scottie Pippen fan but I can't
appreciate what his mother did and what
he did as far as separating himself uh
from the Rev uh the other athletes that
was in the industry and how contracts
were negotiated and done and Nike uh
having the foresight and ability to
break ground in that area and give uh
the athletes a little bit more control
of uh of their finances and a little bit
more stake in into the company so on
those merits alone I give it a three
popcorn it was something good to watch
it was something nice to watch it's it's
when it hits Netflix or HBO Max or you
know something like that Amazon Prime
check it out is it something I'm gonna
tell you to run out and go check out not
really unless you're a huge Michael
Jordan fan and you need to know every
little tidbit about it but um other than
that
really solid film uh Ben Affleck like I
said and uh Matt Damon they have magic
and and it works well
I like those origin stories a lot
because I feel like they give a huge
perspective on you know how some of the
biggest brands in the world were built
yeah
um it's like I said social Network's
probably my favorite but there's there's
quite a bit I think
anything that's now obviously is
Everything 100 no like that they've been
very vocal that a lot of
a lot of changes in movies is strictly
for the audience they don't because some
things don't translate over to to you
know to entertainment as well but but I
definitely like those I I I think the
one I'm gonna watch definitely that you
recommend is that five star of the
Covenant I think I'm definitely going
yeah you're gonna like it you're gonna
like it a lot so
I went and watched the Evil Dead rise
it was it was what you would expect from
Evil Dead now
it's different kind of scenario you
don't normally have the Evil Dead that
we want that I watch because most the
time they're in like the middle of the
Woods
um I was watching the TV show but I
never finished it but most of the time
they're isolated you know what I'm
saying like right besides the immediate
friends in the facility you don't like
the demon doesn't really come in contact
with anyone else does that make sense
yeah that makes sense and this you're
they're in an apartment complex
and the whole top floors
uh attendance
is pretty much interacting with this
demon and
it's do you feel like a horror movie
should be scary the entire time because
I feel like my movie theater is cracking
jokes the whole movie
um do you think that if people are
laughing more than they're they're
feeling like on the edge or or scared to
a point do you think that's a fell of a
horror movie or do you think that to
older audiences such as ourselves or
certain audiences we're going to find
some of the stuff funny
I come from Urban uh background so
you go into the movie theaters you know
black people always talking and snapping
on the phone it was a black dude like
three hours back that he was cracking me
up dude he I I couldn't stop laughing
like like there's this part where this
chick gets destroyed he's like she dead
you see so it's it's I I don't know man
I I will have to probably see it for
myself but if there's too much of Law
and too much uh there's not enough
tension I think scary movies are
supposed to have that tension like you
know you know Pope's Exorcist it got
that tension throughout the whole thing
I feel like the tension and smiles was
good like I I actually got tension
watching smile did you watch smile no no
I didn't watch it it smile
is a very tension movie this movie I
felt like they tried to do tension and
I'm not even saying they did it a bad
way but what I am saying is somewhere
between the line
it just got too comical like there's
this one part I'm gonna spoil some of
this stuff for you guys not anything
serious but she was in front of this
door and you know like the Peeping hole
things and so they're looking out and
they see it because the mother gets
possessed that's in the trailers so
she's sitting there because she's like
she has like her she's way close up to
she's pretty much like this
now they toss her out there and they
shut the door right and they lock it and
it pans back and you just see her
running left to right killing people and
it's yeah like it and it was it was some
gory deaths like some gory deaths so
it's just like look
this is exactly how I would expect an
evil dead like it's like
I don't think that no one ever expects
like an um like an Ultimate Experience
watching Evil Dead uh I spent too much
money on it so I think I I do think I
took a little L there spent like 60
bucks and all oh God and it's not like
it wasn't a bad move it's just
I do enjoy the Evil Dead movies to a
point so I was worth to me it was worth
giving them that money to make sure the
franchise sticks around you know what
I'm saying or at least do my part to
make sure the franchise so so let me ask
you a question
um I watched almost all of them
is this ranked higher or or lower on the
scale of Evil Dead movies
um about Metal
I would say it's definitely better
than your general Evil Dead
especially some of the characters I feel
like they did really well
I do think do you ever take points when
you feel like
the story and some things doesn't make
sense that would happen in real life
like the staircases get destroyed
somehow and they're on the top floor but
they showed that someone came out from a
lower floor and the staircases work fine
so clearly like let's say there's 10
floors uh you know this floor here is
five so everything down is okay because
she she walked down just fine and these
three floors are messed up or however
many floors it was and I'm just thinking
there's a demon and they just they just
destroying everyone I'm gonna take my
chance jumping off the staircase I might
I might get hit hurt a little bit
because there's going to be a little bit
of a drop there but I feel like I got a
better chance crawling down the
staircase if it comes down to that
because this demon this demon grabs you
it's over like you're dead
and I feel like
I can't remember a hundred percent go
ahead and talk
okay I just want to make sure so I I
feel like I have the the mixer right
there and I didn't see your stuff going
at it so I don't remember them using the
book to this degree like I remember the
Book of the Dead being in the in the
evil dead skin it just only opened up
and they used it to find a spell to seal
them up and send them back oh no this
one
it literally used certain like images in
the in the Evil Dead oh like so look
is it the greatest movie in the world no
I I would probably give it a three star
uh you know I think how I would go first
two stars is a no watch three stars look
if you like that type of movie go watch
it four stars is good you should go
watch in five stars what are you doing
exit out of the podcast
and it's just I think it was good uh I
don't I don't expect
like the greatest type of movie when I
watch that but I do expect to be
entertained and I would say I was
entertained
you know they they started with another
scenario that's going on so I like what
they did there and clearly this is going
to be more of these like they they do
have a friend obviously franchise and it
looks like they're they're going it
wasn't like comedy like Army of the Dead
it wasn't like that no no no this this
is comedy that you would have to find
funny it's not deliberately supposed to
be funny it's like like I said like she
she like like imagine like a like a a
shot like this and you see her running
left and right and you see body just
throwing everywhere around the the see
most of the time you wouldn't think
that's funny but me I thought it was
hilarious right because like she would
run this way and you see a body fly this
way and then like everyone was laughing
like pretty like there's a time at the
very beginning where someone was sick on
a bed and they fell off the whole movie
theater just cracked up laughing like
because she's sitting there talking and
she's talking to her and then she's like
are you okay she's just you just hear a
thump
[Laughter]
I'll check it out I'm gonna probably
check it out um when it comes to a
streaming service all right hold on we
got uh Boston Ray with the five dollar
Super Chat I saw Evil Dead definitely
focuses on the jump scares too much I
enjoyed the movie and it's on a higher
level of Evil Dead movies yeah good
thank you
um I don't like
what
um Evil Dead devolved into because the
first Evil Dead was really scary and
trippy
and then when it got to Army of the Dead
it really devolved into something that
was more comical opposed to Something
That was supposed to be frightful and
suspenseful
yeah
I don't think this was generally
directed that I think that they
deliberately made these to be scary but
some people would find them more funny
and that's just what you get now
it's like I said smile
it's all I think it's on uh uh Pandora
Plus or whatever the Panama plus go
watch that like that is a generally
creepy movie my girl was like generally
frightened of that movie like we left we
left the movie it was okay like you know
there's jump scares and like you could
tell that she was getting a little
uncomfortable watching it but I never
felt like she was like let's go
Smiles you made me turn it off
okay so yeah it's a good movie watch
that it's on Prime too wow is a good
movie and I think you should watch it
well definitely check it out yeah and
then well we got Guardians of the Galaxy
this weekend sir
yeah Friday uh
I say we need to
I don't even know I wish I did a guess
if we can get Tyler on yeah we can get
Tyler I'm thinking about uh Spartan lock
yeah we can get a couple of people and
we can you know what we'll probably do
next week because next week's a big
movie because it's not Ant-Man
we'll just go to like a a standard Zoom
call
and just do a standard spoiler cast you
know what I'm saying I'm down for that
man 100 all right um
like I told you guys
you guys need to go uh I would say
the only the only movie I think it's
fair the only movie that's a must watch
is the Covenant from this week yeah yeah
everything else is you know catching on
streaming yeah catch it when it comes
out we ain't telling you go spend your
money on anything but the Covenant Evil
Dead wait wait for it to go on Game Pass
I'm joking
Evil Dead movie is on the Evil Dead game
is on Game Pass like yeah right isn't it
yeah probably so all right so we're
gonna go ahead and uh head out now keep
in mind
uh there is we did get to the
Microsoft Edge on our patreon we are up
to season two we're about almost through
season two of uh Attack on Titan with
King I got some Demon Slayer that me and
my girl reacted to that after he
finished his season two
I'm gonna post that up there
uh King finally found out who the
Colossal Titan are and who the uh who
the armor Titan is
yeah uh so definitely go there check
that I also don't got no legs though or
something I don't know what he does got
like see he's able to like like summon
half of his body if he wants to oh okay
yeah he he pretty much just summoned the
top the topper half of his torso but he
definitely can you see him again King he
definitely got legs that's uh let's see
what they don't tell you is he can make
it to her when he summons his body it's
like a nuke
like a giant explosion so it's going to
be interesting but appreciate everyone
coming through man we had a strong 42 in
here I think that was what it was uh you
guys are definitely going to uh catch
IOP this week uh it's it's it's it's
gonna be a doozy man there's a lot of
stuff to talk about attic shows tomorrow
dirt
yeah um I would ask King to come up I
want him to save his bars for Sunday uh
so I'll probably get uh someone else to
come on but I appreciate it for coming
through and we're gonna go ahead and end
the show King where can people find you
at what you got going on do you you
ready to announce another type of thing
or are you still getting the logistics
on that let's still get Logistics on
that um hey Sunday uh you see Iron Lords
podcast Sunday 1 p.m Eastern Standard
Time
yes it'll be dope yeah yeah I like that
Ramen that Ramen looks nice I need to
have some rum this is the kind of ramen
I want to eat
yo when you come to me the next time I'm
taking you to rock and ramen well Cog
and solver talk to me about coming for
the next video game award thing up there
because apparently Yeah well yeah if
we're on the board
at this point yeah suit it up too you
got to be suited up yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna be great we was laughing
about that in the background
[Laughter]
and you guys catch me on IOP catch me on
a Twitter gaming at it I release the
video today uh definitely go check that
out uh potentially Hellboy 2 might come
out this year there's some uh there's
some
stuff floating around that would say
that that's a good release date might
happen I appreciate everyone for coming
through or we're going to start
redefining the show because I got the
good Rhythm that we want but I do think
we need some things to tone it down to
like to to mainstream it but I'm pretty
sure for coming through we're going to
go ahead and end the show have a nice
day peace this is
thank you
[Music]
foreign